everybody it's time for
pop quiz
okay where is fiona shannon fiona oh
over there
[Applause]
yeah it's 360. look at the white pants
chic with the boots yes
you are so head to toe beautiful and
chic
um if you want correctly answer three
questions about today's show you could
win a thousand dollars what do you think
i'm excited okay
all right
all right first up the highest tea party
on record was just held on top of which
mountain we all know the brits love
their high tea right but it was an
american who just managed to host the
highest high tea on record listen to
this cnn travel report's andrew hughes
hosted a tea party at the very tippy top
of mount everest
mount everest
that's right
that's right that's one question right
you got to get two more correct drew is
stretching she's stressed out i'll
stretch with you i get really nervous
and excited okay second question
what am i doing at ross's wedding you
guys know drew barrymore is my flower
girl at the wedding
oh you're the flower girl yes
all right you got two right
[Music]
i do i get nervous
[Applause]
okay
third question for a thousand dollars
how long does the shrimp dish drew and
pilar cooked take to make
it's coming to me we have a new segment
we're running and it's seven minutes to
make which i love
was it seven minutes
thank you much thank you thank you thank
you you won a thousand dollars and thank
you for making it happen because i get
really upset
when it doesn't work out so i'm glad for
you and thank you for me and my heart
congrats
[Music]